Before we get started, let's make sure you're clear
on when the MapReduce programming model is appropriate and when
it isn't. People use the term big data a lot.
But often data isn't actually that big, in the grand
scheme of things. Some people might tell you that
big data is anything too large to deal with easily
in Excel. That's definitely not the case. It's generally safe
to say that your data is quote unquote big if
it's too large to fit onto one disc. A reasonable
size at which to set the lower bound for big data
at this point in time is probably about five terabytes. For
example, say Google was trying to catalog and index all of
the books in the world to find out which words
have appeared most often. It'd be impossible to load the text
from all the books in the world into a single disc.
It's simply too much data. This is when we should look
to the MapReduce programming model. Beyond this first
constraint, because of the specifics of the MapReduce
programming model, MapReduce only works for tasks where
you hope to employ many workers simultaneously who do
not have knowledge of each other's actions. Why
is that? MapReduce splits a large job up into
several smaller chunks that each fit onto one
machine and occurs simultaneously. These machines do not communicate
with each other while performing their
computations. Certain tasks, that would be very
easy to do using a SQL-like database or simple Python script, can become very
complex when attempting to do them
using MapReduce. Because of this, the smartest
thing to do is to only use MapReduce when your data is truly big.